carefully and quietly Shawn Carla's
parlor approaches the Flamingo watching
from afar he doesn't want to startle the
bird flamingos are his passion different
flamingos are all looking highly unusual
birds so it's easy to get people
interested in them even those who don't
care about environmental protection and
I said about him
alarum is happy to see the birds flock
to e beats us las salinas salt flats
he's counted hundreds of them already
and their numbers have been on the rise
in recent years that's good news for the
Spanish island but mass tourism is
posing a danger to the birds
las salinas no copula las condiciones de
tranquila de las salinas has become too
busy for them to bring up their young in
April when the breeding season begins
most adult birds fly away to reproduce
because in spring flocks of tourists
descend on Ibiza which has become known
as the Mediterraneans number one party
destination as visitor numbers soar the
environment is a price and most
holidaymakers couldn't care less a road
leads straight through the salinas
national park to a highly popular beach
which is teeming with visitors even in
low season tourists stop to snap
pictures of the exotic birds
some even stray into the Nature Reserve
well that's the only way to get to
really see these birds unfortunately
that's how it is when you enter a Nature
Reserve you enter to see the birds in
their actual habitat not like in a zoo
Paul airfields this kind of behavior has
to stop not Salinas where the
Phoenicians began producing salt 2,000
years ago has plenty of plankton and
small crabs for flamingos to feed on
it's an ideal breeding ground for the
birds as Palermo
were it not for the tourists most of
them simply don't know how to act
appropriately in nature Park Rangers
could help but they don't exist here
there's just not enough money even
though the flamingo's could help change
the island's party image as the balearic
islands environmental ministry hopes
that way Ibiza could become an eco
tourism destination symbolic flamingos
have come to stand for a clean
environment and they're apparently
pulling in visitors the birds are giving
the party island Ibiza a totally new
image killaby's a little flamingos but
protecting these species is costly and
limits mass tourism and palarm says the
government is unwilling to risk that he
says this is inconsistent this year many
dead flamingos have been discovered
across the island in January alone 21
dead birds were found
[Music]
laughs I will see several Ethan we don't
know if the animals are examined to
ascertain the cause of their death one
of all kinds of diseases not just
conventional ones are being looked into
we have no information on this I almost
think the government isn't taking this
problem seriously
Emiliano este the one dozen serial
problem I know Palermo thinks the
problem is being swept under the rug he
believes all the talk of sustainability
is just an empty marketing ploy well
again I don't think there'll be a change
in course maybe they're trying to
attract other kinds of holidaymakers
they're not taking action against mass
tourism and definitely doing nothing to
stop the party tourism it's all about
the money tourists are bringing to the
islands as John Carlos parlare the
flamingos simply can't compete with that
so their numbers might soon be dwindling
[Music]
you